hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast gee doc plus a data science
platform for precision medicine research
I am Judy O'Rourke of leopards and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminars
presented by labyrinth the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning we'd also like to acknowledge
the sea and en media group for help with
programming and promotion of this event
we have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive we encourage you to
ask questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on a green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CD button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I would now
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
suba Madhavan dr. suba Madhavan is
director of the innovation center for
biomedical informatics at the Georgetown
University Medical Center and associate
professor of oncology she is a
world-class leader in data science
clinical informatics and health IT who
is responsible for several biomedical
informatics efforts including the
software development of the Georgetown
database of cancer gee doc a resource
for both researchers and clinicians to
realize the goals of personalized
medicine and she co-directs the Lombardi
Cancer Centers biostatistics and
bioinformatics shared resource
if you would like more information about
our speaker please click on her photo
image in the top right the planners for
this event has stated no relevant
financial relationships however dr.
Kevin Davies did disclose that he is a
scientific advisory board member for
pathway genomics and is on the speaker's
bureau for Harry Walker incorporated and
that neither can constitute a conflict
of interest please note that dr. Madigan
has indicated that she has no relevant
financial relationships relative to this
topic I will now turn it over to dr.
Madigan for her presentation hello
everybody thank you Judy and thank you
lab roots for inviting me to speak about
gee doc Georgetown database of cancer so
over the next 40 to 45 minutes I will be
presenting the software platform that's
intended for translational research and
precision medicine research here at
Georgetown University's Lombardi Cancer
Center as well as other collaborators
who work with us on a number of projects
and then we will have about 10 to 15
minutes of a Q&A session giving you an
opportunity to ask questions and bring
up points for discussions about the
topic that I'm going to present to you
today so this platform again it's called
G dot Georgetown database of cancer we
have been working on this translational
research platform for over five years
now at georgetown's Lombardi Cancer
Center this effort is funded by the
National Cancer Institute NHGRI the
genome Institute at the NIH the FDA
mcats and st. Baldrick's Foundation the
goals of the G dot platform are listed
here on this slide the primary purpose
of this effort was to enable
translational research by integrating
patient characteristic
and genotype information genotypic data
in under one umbrella within this
software platform to allow for unified
access to this information so really the
primary goal is genotype-phenotype
integration we also wanted to offer
workflows in precision medicine
translational research and population
genetics to our end users so when I say
end users our typical users are clinical
researchers or basic scientists who are
not computer programmers so they really
need an application or a user interface
where they could connect the genotype
and phenotype data and ask interesting
questions so those are the target
audience for this platform we also
wanted to take advantage of cloud
computing and other Big Data
technologies that are emerging to
provide access to large-scale genomic
information through the G dot platform
the gtalk platform uses our in-house
architectural framework we built this
architectural framework at Georgetown
University currently supports over a
thousand users and contains data from
over 10,000 patients or cell line
information the only criteria we use to
select the data sets to load into g doc
is that that particular study or the
data set must contain some kind of omics
information it could be genomic data it
could be transcriptomics or metabolomic
information but we also need some
critical information associated with
that study so that's our criteria for
selecting studies to be loaded into the
g doc platform as i mentioned it
provides support for transcriptomics
studies mi RNA expression copy number
variation metabolomic data and whole
genome sequencing information it also
contains these large publicly available
data collections such as the thousand
genomes data sets multi omics data from
the NCI sixty profiling data sets and
other cancer studies as well as
cancer studies are available within the
portal the system also supports private
studies or datasets that our
collaborators are working on so we are
able to process them and make them
available through the GI platform and
eventually when the study gets published
the study can be made public within the
gtalk portal it has a broad collection
of analysis tools that are available to
our end users to analyze and investigate
the datasets that are present within the
system it currently supports many
research projects are primarily focused
when we started building this
translational research platform was to
support colon cancer and breast cancer
studies those are two major focus areas
at the Lombardi Cancer Center we have
now since expanded the system to cover
other types of cancers as well as non
cancer studies so you can think of DDOT
as a research data warehouse with a set
of analysis tools that are available to
analyze the genotype phenotype
information let's present within the
platform so I list here a number of
other studies or disease types that are
supported within within gee doc so the
primary mission was to integrate
best-in-class software tools that are
available for a variety of
bioinformatics methods so as you can see
here we integrate the G dot platform
with pathway tools to do network
analysis we integrate it with imaging
tools so users can explore MRI images we
have next generation sequence analysis
tools that are primarily written in
bioconductor in our and those are
integrated within the gtalk platform as
well and other disease classification
tools are available within the g doc
platform to really allow for a single
stop shop so the users do not need to go
into other software platforms while they
are exploring these datasets so all
these tools are available and analysis
methods are available with
the deduct platform for them to analyze
this data we are currently also
integrating with clinical platforms the
EHR system that we use at georgetown's
Lombardi Cancer Center is called aria
it's from company called Varian and we
are currently in the process of
developing integration with our EHR
platform and also a clinical research
platform which was developed out of
Vanderbilt University called red cap so
again the idea is to integrate with
best-in-class software to allow for
users to use this information and
analyze the data in the context of these
tools so in this slide here shows you an
overview of the various features that
are present within the g-dog system as
you can see on the right hand side you
can see that the data sources can either
be public data sources such as from the
ncbi's geo database which is the gene
expression database or the ebi is array
express we can also take data sets from
our collaborators as I mentioned you
know if the data sets are not publicly
available but the data sets are
available through a research consortium
that were part of we are able to take
data sets from our collaborators as well
and there are a number of analysis tools
within the system to analyze copy number
data next-generation sequencing data
medical images metabolomics and
transcriptomics and other variant type
of genomics information where we do not
have by automatic pipelines we develop
our own pipelines de novo but more often
than not there are other standardized by
automatic pipelines that are available
that we have incorporated within the
gtalk system the data is stored in two
different areas here so when the
datasets are large such as large genomic
projects we end up storing those
datasets on the Amazon Cloud so we use
the Amazons f3
bucket which is part of the Amazon Web
Services to store the data and all the
analysis and the compute occur in the
easy two clusters within Amazon Web
Services the data sets are not large or
if there is clinical information and pH
I data about patients we store them
within our secure data center which is
located in Laurel Maryland so depending
on the project and depending on the
security needs of the project we are
able to switch the storage location to
either a local data center or the Amazon
Cloud so once the data is populated with
in the gtalk system there are a number
of tools that are available to explore
these datasets and we also link out to
other public databases so that the users
could annotate the data sets that they
are exploring within gee doc with
information that's present in other
databases this is the URL for the g doc
website so it's gtown edu we have over a
thousand users this light is not updated
I apologize for that so we have over a
thousand users in the system and we have
about 10,000 patients or cell line data
within this research data warehouse so
if you log into gtalk edu and register
you will be able to explore the publicly
available studies so here's a quick
review of the cloud computing
architecture that is in place to support
gee doc this is these are all AWS
resources so they are on demand so we
are able to call upon these ec2 nodes as
and when there is a need to do
high-throughput compute all the large
datasets are stored within the s3 bucket
so typically we're able to connect with
the genome sequences so in this example
I mentioned in one of my previous slides
that we obtain data from come from
Complete Genomics we were able to
connect directly with Complete Genomics
ss3
bucket so the data gets moved from us
vest Coast s3 bucket to the east coast
bucket which was our bucket so
essentially the data gets stored in
India's three buckets and then the ec2
nodes are invoked for various analysis a
lot of time and effort was spent in in
thinking about you know what sort of
security infrastructure we need to put
in place there's a virtual there's a VPC
connection between the end users and the
Amazon Cloud and there's oughtn't
occation via the VPC for users to
connect to the Amazon Cloud cluster to
access these data sets so this is in the
case of data sets when they're stored on
the Amazon Cloud so in the case where
they're actually stored in our local
data center and there is a different
authentication authorization protocol
that allows users into the system so
here is a quick overview of the kinds of
computes that are available within the
Amazon platform we have implemented
these pipelines through a system called
Globus genomics this was developed by
dr. Ian fastest group at University of
Chicago we closely collaborate with them
to develop these next generation
sequencing data analysis pipelines so
when the data sets say from complete
genomics or other provider or our own
sequencing machines at Georgetown we
then preprocess them using these by
enzymatic pipelines before they get
loaded into gtalk for analysis so again
here is the URL for the system and users
but even before they login can see the
datasets can see what types of data sets
are available there are muscular
dystrophy studies there are infectious
diseases studies and other types of
cancer studies that are available within
the platform and you can see this even
before you log into the system and
there's the little link here up top on
the right hand side to register within
the system and it takes just a few
seconds if you click on register
and you create a username and password
and you can browse and analyze these
data sets again this is just a launchpad
I will be going into more details of the
various features within within the
system and show you a quick demo if
you're interested in learning more about
the genome platform and the architecture
there's a paper we published in
neoplasia a few years ago that goes into
more details about the the architecture
as well as the kinds of data that we
load into the system so let's take a
look at how to navigate these data sets
within gee doc so here's the front page
so even before you log in you can
explore these data sets to understand
what types of data sets are available
and the and depending on the research
questions or the hypothesis that you
would like to generate you can select a
study of interest so you log in here and
as I mentioned you can just click on
register where the blue arrow shows and
you can quickly register to get into the
platform and once you login this is the
view that you will see it takes you to
the G dot launch pad and there is a box
here that says it all starts here it'll
help you there's a visit type interface
that will help you pick a study for your
analysis within G dot so once you click
on that it'll take you to this window
and there are three different types of
workflows that are possible you can do
precision medicine type analysis to look
at individual patients you can conduct
translational research analysis where
you can select a translational research
study and conduct radius by enzymatic
analysis you can also do population
genetics type of analysis so for today's
discussion i'm going to focus on
translational research and here i'm
showing you a brain tumor study which is
the study that i want to select so once
you click on on brain tumor it will show
you
the various types of studies that are
available under the brain tumor category
you can click on more to learn more
about this study that we are going to
choose today it's called the Rembrandt
study it was started and funded by the
National Cancer Institute and this data
set is publicly available and published
in a number of number of peer-reviewed
journal articles so that is the study
that we're going to select for
explanation within g dot so once you
select the study it then provides you
with the menu of options so you could do
you could search the gene expression
data or you could search the clinical
data the system is will provide you with
options depending on the types of omics
data that are available within the
platform so let's say the study had
proteomics and metabolomics datasets
those will be listed here as well so in
this study there is transcriptomics data
and there is clinical information and
you could also invoke any of these
analysis tools to look at to analytic
data within this study so I selected on
my previous screen that I want to
explore the clinical data and that takes
me to this screen here and you can use
any of these menu options on the
left-hand panel to further filter the
data set and here you can see these are
the data elements that are already
available as part of this study so it's
very study specific so you only show you
those data elements that are available
for you to filter the data by right now
I've chosen to look at the data by
disease type so recall that this is a
brain tumor study and here I have
various types of brain tumors listed and
the number of subjects that are present
for each of those data types so we have
oligodendroglioma 86 patients
astrocytoma 170 patients and GBM 261
patients and let's say that I want to
compare the gene expression profiles
between gilma gear blastoma multi for me
which is the worst form of brain tumor
with astrocytomas and that's the
workflow that I'm going to take you
through so you can click on the number
here so basically on astrocytoma
170 patients and for GBM we have 261
patients and I can save that list I can
save that clinical list as a straw or
GBM you can give it a custom name for
this chemical list and now my two lists
are saved so I've saved the astrocytoma
group I've saved the GBM group and I'd
like to do a group compares them between
these two groups using the gene
expression data so when I click on group
comparison this green shows up and I can
select the groups that I have just saved
so as you can see up top I'm selecting
the astrocytomas as my baseline group
and the dbms as my experimental group
and I want the p-value when I compare
these to be at least point zero zero
zero one so I'm really looking for
significant hits and I do want to do a
multiple pairs and adjustment
Corrections using FDR and the data type
that I want to select this gene
expression data these are all defaults
that are available within the platform
and as I mentioned in my introduction
the target audience for this group are
clinical researchers or basic scientists
so we want to try and avoid you know
writing code or any any type of complex
analysis so a lot of defaults are
available to allow our end users to
explore the data sets and so that's the
comparison we will do here so once i run
the group comparison it's available
within the notifications tab it'll tell
me when the group comparison is complete
so all of these analysis are occurring
in an analysis cluster that's running in
the back end and it's it's it's pretty
quick so this example that I showed you
it took a couple of seconds to run and
this is the affymetrix whole genome
array for about 170 astrocytomas about
200 GBM cases so once you click on the
results of your group comparison you can
now see the various reporters or genes
that are listed that are different
between the astrocytoma group and the
GBM group it actually gives you a little
indication here on the type of analysis
that you conducted on this data
set up top it tells you that you
compared astrocytoma and GBM and these
are the parameters that you had set up
and these are the results of group
comparison as as you can see and and the
blue links here indicate that you can
click on them and it'll take you to
other public databases if you wanted to
learn more about these dreams so you can
then select these genes and you can save
them either either just as genes or you
can save them as reporters in the
affymetrix array platform you have
multiple reporters that can measure the
expression of a single gene so if you
decide to choose at a much more granular
level you could save the data by
reporters and then you could run a
classification on the genes or reporters
that you have saved and those options
are available under the study options so
I'm going to choose classification here
so basically what we have done is we
have taken the astrocytoma group and the
GBM group we save the clinical a data
set for each of them the pay the patient
list and then we ran a class comparison
experiment to see which are the genes
that are up or down regulated when you
compare these two groups so once I've
done that I'm now interested in seeing
based on this gene expression data can I
actually run a principal component
analysis to classify these patients and
that's this analysis so you can choose
the two groups that you want to run the
classification on and here are the
results so once you run it you will show
you a PCA plot and you can see here the
red dots are astrocytoma samples and the
green dots here are from glioblastoma
and you can see that there is a clear
separation although there are some
astrocytoma patients whose molecular
profiles are beginning to look like gbms
so so that could be indicative of you
know how the molecular biology is
telling us more than what we can
understand from from pathology so maybe
these astrocytomas have molecular
profiles that are very similar to DBMS
that's giving us an indication of what
sort of treatment planning we may have
do for these patients that are embedded
within the GBM group certain exploratory
analysis you could also do a survival
analysis you can run a kaplan-meier
survival plot based on either gene
expression data or clinical data on the
study if there are other data types
available as part of that study you
could also run a km plot based on that
so the captain Maya plot is going to
allow me to see how the segregation is
in terms of survival between these two
groups and so I can select I can go back
to the two selecting the groups again
I've now selected the astrocytomas and
gbms and I'm interested in looking at
overall survival in in terms of months
right so and then immediately comes back
the result for the camp lot and I can
see here that the gbms had poorer
survival compared to the astrocytoma see
astrocytomas had longer survival
compared to the dbms and it also shows
you a log-rank p-value which is pretty
significant this is a known fact we know
that the gbms performed poorly compared
to other types of brain tumors you can
also run this can plot based on gene
expression data so so this was sort of
just the tip of the iceberg on the set
of features I encourage all of you who
are listening to this lecture to log
into the G doc system and register and
try out some of these analysis yourself
and there are a number of public data
sets that are available and then you can
play with so the system just to quickly
summarize here it allows to generate new
hypothesis from existing data we can
perform in silico meta-analysis and
compare disparate studies there's
obviously added value in obtaining new
insights from already published data
sets by reanalyzing the published data
sets you might be able to gain new
insights into those studies you know
something may not have been a particular
result may not have been called out in
that complication but you can explore
further from these published published
data sets and also aid in new hypothesis
generation for your own own research
thank you if you so choose to do so so
what I want to do in the next 15-20
minutes is go through a
scientific study that we have used gtalk
to analyze so I've shown you a various
set of features now I will now show you
a scientific example of how the deduct
system can be used to answer their
specific set of questions in stage 2
colorectal cancers so just to set the
stage here I want to briefly describe
the study the in stage 2 colon cancers
about eighty percent of these patients
are cured after surgery about twenty
percent of them end up having relapse
after many years of treatment so today
as it stands early stage colon cancers
after surgery everybody is hit with with
chemotherapy if we could on the day of
surgery predict which patients may recur
versus not then we could titrate the
treatments based on that information so
on the day of surgery we want to know
which patients are going to relapse and
which ones not we basically want to know
which are the just a twenty percent of
the patients that we should treat and
the rest that we don't need to do
anything because they're cured after
surgery so that was the primary
hypothesis behind the study can we
collect multi ohmic data sets that can
tell us which patients are going to
relapse and which ones are not going to
relapse so in this study we collected in
in 40 patients we collected data on you
know tumor on on tumor DNA and so we had
adjacent normals so the tumor tissue was
collected and adjacent normals were
collected and DNA was extracted from
them and the same was true for RNA data
RNA was extracted from fumer as well as
normal tissue we also collected serum
and urine and micro RNA rrnas were
extracted from serum and metabolites
were expected votes from see demand and
urine so the idea was to see if if there
could be a multi ohmic profile that
could help us predict which patients are
going to relapse versus not and we did
the same for the V last cases and we had
a long-term follow-up at least five
years on many patients we had more than
10 years of follow-up so we knew which
patients had relapsed and which ones not
and he also had Sam
was collected on the day of surgery and
we had over 100 our clinical attributes
on these patients so here is the summary
of our analysis let me show you the
summary first and then I'll walk you
through the types of buyin thematic
analysis we did on each of those data
types so different colors here indicate
the different different data types that
we looked at with in this study the red
here shows the the gene expression data
the green here shows the micro RNA data
the blue shows the copy number data the
pink here are serum metabolites the
positive channelside metabolites and the
purple is negative channel serum
metabolites and the light blue shows
uden metabolites and the dark blue shows
urine metabolites negative channel so we
started out with over 12,000 markers in
our feature matrix so when we had
measured each one of using each one of
these experiments we had about 12,000
features and using a number of biomes
Matic approaches and data reduction
approaches we ended up with the 31 panel
marker set so we ended up with a 31
panel prognostic set that was a
combination of gene expression micro RNA
copy number and metabolomics data and
that could tell that with very high
accuracy could predict which patients
we're going to relapse versus not so
again starting from about 12,000
features we ended up with 31 features
that can very accurately predict which
ones we're going to relapse and which
patients were not going to relapse so
now let me walk you through each of the
individual data types so first I'm going
to show you the gene expression data so
what we did with the gene expression
data is the type of group comparison
that we looked at in the example that I
showed you when comparing astrocytomas
to 2gb ms so we did a very similar
analysis so we took the relapse cases
and Anand relapse cases and they
compared the gene expression data sets
and we came up with the list of genes
that were either over or under expressed
between these two groups and then did a
pathway analysis so if you recall the G
dot diagram that I showed you there are
a number
of pathway tool is available within the
G doc system to allow us to do this sort
of network analysis so what you're
looking at here is an output of a
network analysis that is showing the up
or down regulated genes then we compared
the relapse and the non relapse cases
what was interesting from this analysis
was all these genes that you see
highlighted in yellow were all immune
related genes so it was already
beginning to tell us the nice scientific
story so when we compared the relapse
cases in the non relapse cases we were
beginning to see that the immune
response genes such as chemokines for
example CXC 11 we also had see cams we
had chcl 13 that were upregulated in the
in the relapse cases compared to the non
relapse cases so it was beginning to
tell us a very important immune related
story here so we then looked at the copy
number data and using gtalk tools to
analyze which are the regions that were
either amplified or deleted in the
relapse cases compared to the non
relapse cases and mean when we did an
enrichment analysis of the region's the
site two bands that were either
amplified or deleted and we map them to
what biological mechanisms those regions
within the chromosomes maybe more then
again it started to point us towards an
immune response story so there were
amplifications or deletions in the t
cell activation there were
amplifications or deletions in the
immune response pathways and this was
again collaborating with our gene
expression story so that was the gene
expression data we then looked at a
number of variants that came out so this
is through the next-gen sequencing data
set so we employed an exome sequencing
technique so basically be sequenced all
the the human exomes in both the relapse
as well as non relapse cases and this
was a standardized pipeline that was
used to process the next-generation
sequencing data from the fast cue files
all the way through to VCF files and
also the copy number
data sets can be analyzed using the
exone data set so here's the here's a
quick review of the pipeline that was
used on amazon cloud to analyze this
data and when we looked at the variants
that were present in the relapse cases
meaning they were only present in the
cases so as you can see in this table
you see the column that says variants
and number of cases that had these
variants these variants were present
only in the cases not in the controls so
the cases were the relapse cases and the
controls were the non-dairy non relapse
and these variants in these jeans were
present only in the relapse cases and
when we did a pathway enrichment
analysis lo and behold again we see
t-lymphocytes p10 signaling and all
claims of T cell and B cell signaling so
it's actually it was begging to
corroborate the story that we were
seeing with the gene expression data and
really telling us a very interesting
immune response story here so the
patients that were were not showing
relapse already had immune infiltration
so basically the immune cells were
showing up in this tissue in the in the
non relapse cases on the patients that
did not have real ads had very high
infiltration of immune cells so that led
us to looking at the dual pathological
analysis so basically look at the slides
to see if we could say anything about
immune infiltrate and I will show you
that in a second but before that I want
to show you the metabolomics data so
here's the pipeline that was used for
the metabolomic analysis so like I
mentioned when I explained the system to
you early on that you know where there
were bands matic pipelines that were
available we adopted them in the case of
metabolomics metabolomics is such a new
field that there weren't existing
pipelines that we could use for this
project so we developed a pipeline on
our own and this this pipeline is
already published how do you go from the
mg XML data from the mass spec all the
way through to putative metabolites we
have built this pipeline
it's published in the Journal of
metabolomics which you can you can look
it up but this is the the core of that
paper and basically you know the
highlighters of this pipeline is that
you know once the the mass by charge
ratio once the peaks are identified we
then match those Peaks to nine different
databases to identify the putative
metabolites so not just one or two
databases we wanted to see if there were
other annotations that are present in
these in these databases to tell us what
are these metabolites that are different
between these two groups and we then
connected to stitch another database
that can link gene expression data to
metabolomic data so we can ask all kinds
of interesting questions you know we
knew which are the genes that were over
or under expressed and using that
information we were able to use the
stitch database to act the question more
than any connections between the
metabolites and gene expression data
that could further tell us anything more
about the immune response story that we
were we were trying to build so here are
some quick classification results the
panels here show the metabolomics data
sources for bio fluid based markers so
I'm showing you here the auto seekers
for the amendment the metabolomic
experiment we used a machine learning
approach called SVM rfv it's a support
vector machine leave-one-out methodology
so basically what it does is it keeps
reducing the number of features until
you end up with a set of features that
can clearly separate the two groups so
if you left one more feature out you
will not be able to get that clear
separation so that's the machine
learning approach it's called support
vector machines which was used here and
we got very good auc curves on these so
basically you know close to ninety
percent accuracy in classification using
just the bio fluid based based markers
the gene expression data was pretty good
as well but the the bio fluid based
metabolomic markers gave us a much
better classification here are the key
metabolites that were involved so we
call the
immune response story that we were
trying to build with the gene expression
copy number Davis said and they were
furious to see what the metabolomics
data sets are telling us and as you can
see here the metabolites that were
altered in the relapse cases compared to
the non relapse cases again ended up to
be those that were mediated in immune
response so we found four hydroxy to
butanoic acid which is mediate which is
involved in t and b cell mediated
response we also found other metabolites
that were involved in other immune
diseases such as crohn's disease and
also carnitine metabolites which are
known to be involved in immune or
inflammatory responses so again there
was the corroboration between all these
data types that that we were seeing so
reproducibility in science is an active
debate now and we're all looking at you
know how we could potentially produce
results that were already published by
other groups and relating to that
reproducibility discussion is
corroboration so can there be multiple
data types that can give us similar
results or point us in the right
direction in terms of in terms of
discovery so so this type of
corroboration type experiments can be
done in an in silico fashion within
within the GDR platform so here's the
slide staining that I was talking about
so we asked the question are there
infiltrating lymphocytes in the non
relapse cases compared to the relapse
cases so the top panel that you see are
the the non relapse the ones that did
not record and then the bottom panel are
the relapse cases and as you can see in
slide section b that there are these
brown spots there are these little brown
spots that you can see in panel B that
clearly indicate that there were much
higher infiltration of of lymphocytes in
the non relapse group so essentially
there is a there is a protection that's
given to these tissue because of this
infiltration of off lymphocytes and this
is the well-known fact so we're not the
first ones that are making this I those
hypotheses it's a known fact that in
many cancers we see infiltration of
lymphocyte that confer protection
against worse worse
comes now here is an example of multi
ohmic data integration we used a system
which was developed by the Institute of
systems biology it's called regular
Explorer we use this this is called a
circus plot many of you may be familiar
with this the circus plot is a way to
show a variety of genomic features on a
circular plot like this and you can
actually map those features to
individual chromosomes so what you're
you're seeing here are the features that
were mapped to chromosome 12 chromosome
3 chromosome 4 and so on and the
different colors here show the different
types of data that we can plot on these
on these data sets um and so so the
primary purpose of the circles plot is
to see are their hubs within the genome
right so if you actually look at this
post plot you can see that there's a lot
of activity in chromosome 3 and
chromosome 4 for example right and
chromosome 4 deletions are very known
and well documented in stage 2 colon
cancer so the primary purpose here is to
see there are the major activities so
that we could hone in on those specific
chromosomal regions okay so once the
look at the circles plot and we see what
are the features that may be involved we
can we can then so what we are seeing
here is just the network of those
features a combination of features that
came out of the support vector machine
analysis and these different colors
indicate the different data types so the
brown indicates here these are
metabolites the blue ones are the gene
expression data you will recall the CXC
11 and chcl 13 from the network diagram
that we were looking at the the red ones
here are also metabolites the brown ones
are unit metabolites and the red ones
are cedar metabolites you also see some
micro RNA data so this is now really
bringing together all of the data types
that were filtered for those features
that were different between the the
relapse and the non relapse cases and
you can
see them in 11 view and they are all
inflammatory markers so so basically you
know when you look up the biology of
these individual markers it's clear that
there is a there is an immune story that
all of these data points are trying to
tell us so this is the end result
starting from about 12,000 features
applying these these violence matic
approaches they are able to arrive at
the most informative 31 features that
can tell us more about the etiology and
the biology of relapse in in colon
cancers so we can further use the
network modeling a diagram here to
better understand what's going on across
these data types and when we plotted the
31 features we actually see that there
is a connection to a hub this is fast
fast hub which is actually a tnf
receptor protein in all of these these
genes and metabolites seem to be
operating through this centralized hub
so so using gtalk you could sort of
filter down and arrive at the most
informative features but you could also
do these sorts of network enrichment
analysis to understand better the
biology and begin to generate new
hypothesis that you want to test in the
lab or design a new new clinical assay
so what we've done so far is just a
quick review we looked at the georgetown
database of cancer it's a publicly
available database so i encourage you to
go look at it g danke Shon edu you can
register and look at the public data
sets there and as datasets become public
there are some private data sets which
are primarily for the investigators that
collaborate with us once the data sets
are published we make them available in
the public sandbox you can explore them
you can analyze these data sets once you
log in you can start with the study you
start with the study you pick a study
you go through the analysis we've shown
you the sort of high-level features
within gee doc we've also taken one
example of stage 2 colon cancers and
have walked through a variety of biomes
matic analysis that you can use to fill
down the results from big data into
something that is much more useful and
comprehensible to designing your your
future experiments so that's what we've
done today and if you're interested in
understanding more about this research
there's a paper we published on the
stage 2 colon cancer study in frontiers
in cancer genetics and you can look up
that study for lot more details about
the method on the various methodologies
that that were used so here are my
coordinates in case there are any
questions or feedback that you'd like to
reach reach out to me feel free to email
me at Subic madhavan at josh on da video
so i see that we are exactly at a 45
minute mark we had planned for about 15
minutes of Q&A and I will stop there and
we will take questions thank you
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the QA I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can and our first question is were the
metabolites measured untargeted in
parentheses full change measures or
quantitative targeted measures
quantitative targeted measures yes so
that's a good question so the the
metabolites were measured untargeted and
we once we did the first set of
experiments using untargeted this was
all done using tandem mass spec analysis
and once he identified those select
metabolites that were different between
the the Leal acts on the non-dairy labs
case this we did some targeted
validation so for the the carnitine
metabolites and some of the others that
i mentioned that were different between
the relaxant on relapse cases we did
targeted validation and I believe
there's a related question about
controls yes in the urine metabolized
they were normalized to to creatinine so
so first untargeted tandem mass spec and
then identification of the metabolites
that were different in the relapse cases
using the pipeline that I described and
then we get targeted validation for the
the the peaks that were different
between the two groups so let me know he
answered the second part of this
three-part question were internal
standards used the three-part question
word internal standards use
yes so we used we used internal
standards on the metabolomics I think
you know so we normalized it to two
other known metabolites when the
untargeted metabolomics experiments were
conducted such as 22 creatinine yes
internal control controls were used what
were the units for urine metabolites
measured normalized to creatinine and
life measured normalized you creatinine
yes that's that's correct these were all
M by Z values those are the raw raw
Peaks that come out of the tandem mass
spec essays and once the once we use the
the once the peak identification is done
then we match them to the nine databases
and identify the putative the period of
metabolites but the the units for the
the output from the mass spec
experiments are just the M by Z values
basically the mass by charge is there a
steep learning curve to get to know gee
doc for a non computing scientist to get
to know G dot 49 computing scientist so
that's that's an interesting question so
we've actually tried to target gee doc
for a non computer scientist you have
tried to target G dot for a non computer
scientist so the and the users are
typically basic scientists or clinical
researchers and that's our target target
audience I would say that you know in
the last few years that you know we've
had people use the system I highly
recommend that they watch the
tutorial video so there are a number of
videos video tutorials that are
available within gee doc and you can
watch those and typically after watching
those videos people are able to use the
various features within the platform we
also try to do some online training
sessions we typically do that for groups
that are collaborating with us so if
there are grant groups you know if the
consortia grant is funded and a group of
people want to use gtalk we tend to do
online training for those groups as well
very targeted to their use cases so I
would say that the learning curve for
the non computer scientist is not huge
but definitely taking the training
looking at the cleaning videos is
helpful another attendee asks once once
registered can we load up data sets to
test run the system the offense
sometimes one this is done yeah so
currently the Vegas system is built so
the question is you know can you can you
load your own data sets to to test from
the system once so the way the system is
built right now you have to work with us
to load the data so there's no user
interface to upload your own data sets
so there's a G dot help email which you
can you can email to deduct a shell but
josh kroenke d you and the team will be
assigned to work with you to load the
data but we have to right now there's no
mechanism for users to upload their own
information using the interface but we
are in the process of building that and
that would enable people to load the
data themselves and as you can imagine
you know with these data sets the
biggest challenge is mapping to
standards and quality control so we
really want to control the data that
goes into the system so that there's
high quality data that's available to
our end users and you know we we take
the priority
the study is based on the funding that's
available to support that study so we
typically tend to work with users who
are able to you know work with us on a
funded project so we'd obviously
prioritize their data sets to get those
data sets into the system and you know
we then map them to standards and you
know do quality control on those data
sets before they get loaded into the
into the system so right now there's no
mechanism for users to directly upload
their data using the user interface but
you can contact us and we can work with
you to load the data into the system
okay looks like we have time for one
last question so it is if our data set
is loaded up with your help cannot be
kept private or will it become public
now you can't private owners become
public yeah so the data set can be kept
private so there is this a mechanism to
keep the data sets public and or keep
the data sets private when the
experimentalists or the users want to
load their data they can let the team
know whether they want to keep this
private or public and we can keep it
private until the information is
published and so that way the data sets
in the public private sandbox are only
available to users that have uploaded
this data and the users that they have
given access to so you can have a
restricted group of people who can you
know access these datasets and analyze
the data sets in the private private
confines of a workspace and then once
it's published you you can make it make
it problem so yes the data set can be
kept private within the system
I would like to once again thank dr.
Madigan for her presentation do you have
any final comments for us today venetian
do you have any final comments for us
today No thank you very much for this
opportunity and a great Q&A session I
encourage everybody who is either
generating data or doing translational
research to go check out the platform we
are always looking for a good input on
how we could improve this platform so
any feedback there would be helpful
thank you for your time and thank you
for listening today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
August of 2016 you'll receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to afford that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event see you next time
goodbye